[Music]
Sesame Street has been teaching kids
valuable lessons for more than 50 years
but how to stay safe during the corona
virus pandemic may be the most important
yet the organization launched the caring
for each other initiative to help
families stay healthy and tonight the
new primetime special Sesame Street
Elmo's playdate will show kids how they
can sing and play together while apart
[Music]
[Applause]
and only on CBS this morning Big Bird
joins us from his nest on Sesame Street
hi big bird great to see you again
hi how are you look good morning good
morning big bird you've been hanging out
with your friends but things are a
little things are a little different
right now
what are your playdates like these days
well you know things are a little bit
different like you say but but Alan set
up this really neat video chat for me so
I could keep in touch with all my
friends on Sesame Street kind of like
like we're doing right now
Tony the important play date you've got
a particularly important play date
coming up tonight what can you tell us
about it are you gonna be with and what
are you guys gonna do well yeah well
tonight I have a video chat with Elmo
and Grover a Cookie Monster and end my
friends and Hathaway and lin-manuel
Miranda and Tracee Ellis Ross oh and
you're invited too of course
Oh we'll accept that invitation Big Bird
it's really good to see you I haven't
seen you in so long you look like you've
lost a little weight you look good but
this is what I'm thinking
yeah you look yeah I think it's never
good you're welcome
I think it's never good to keep your
feelings bottled up inside so I'm
wondering how you're feeling these days
and why you think it's so important for
us to express our feelings talk about it
well well my granny bird says that it's
important to talk about about your
feelings and and sometimes you have
those big feelings and little feelings
and when that happens for me I just give
my teddy bear radar a big hug and and I
make it makes me feel better and and
sometimes like I take a few really deep
breaths and that helps too big bird
there's there's some there's some kids
out there big bird
who might be who might be feeling scared
or lonely right now well what would you
say to them
no well I think that even though things
are a little bit different right now
well we're all in this together and it's
important to to help out and to be kind
and we can lend a hand or a way in my
case and we can help each other and you
can you can send somebody a virtual hug
how about that it's a good idea big bird
you know big we're we're all we're all
stuck in our nests these days and it
seems like we've been stuck here forever
and I don't know when we're gonna get
out so what do we do to stay healthy
what have you been doing to stay healthy
while you're in your nest well well you
Tony you have to get up and move yeah so
every night we have virtual dance
parties together and we have a lot of
fun we just kind of move and shake we
also know Big Bird it's very important
to wash your hands you know I think
people are washing their hands more than
they ever have before and people are
coming up with different songs help them
get through it other than happy birthday
so do you have a special song that you
do when you're washing won your case
your wings for us the rest of us it's
hands yes yeah I I do yes I wash my my
hands work for 20 seconds and I see
sunny days sweeping up so play on my way
to where the air is sweet and they sing
that two times in a good we'll try
singing that at home to Big Bird thank
you so much for being with us
you can watch Elmo's pledge a big bird